All right, so now back to what we're talking about here.
Histamine is an important gene, this HNMT gene,
like this person in this slide,
does not have a lot of HNMT gene defects.
But they still might have a lot of inflammation,
systemic inflammation, even though they don't have any defects
in this pathway.
Why?
Because they have environmental things
that are causing this inflammation.
Remember, histamine is a product of an immune response.
Histamine is made by your mast cells.
And in the presence of an antigen or an allergen,
you're going to produce a lot of histamine.
So when I have a allergy to pollen,
I'm producing a lot of histamine.
That's why I have the symptoms.
Now, normally, if you don't have any HNMT gene defects,
these genes should be working correctly,
should be making the enzyme that breaks down histamine,
it gets it out of your tissue.
So you don't have, quote, unquote, allergies.
Does that make sense?
But if you have a hyper exposure to an allergen,
or you have an autoimmune disease,
or you have an antigen that's present constantly
that you haven't identified nor gotten rid of,
you have this ramped up immune response
that's firing all the time.
So you have excess histamine.
So even in the presence of no genetic defects,
you can still have a histamine problem.
Follow me?
So if the patient has symptoms of hyper inflammation,
systemic inflammation, you want to look at,
from my perspective, I know, why?
First, right?
Why does this person have systemic inflammation?
Do they have an autoimmune issue?
Do they have an immune system that's constantly turned on?
Do they have an antigen that's present?
Do they have HNMT gene defects?
Again, it's one piece of the puzzle.
But if I have a patient that we're only doing
a genetic consultation today and have a whole
won't load of defects here,
they're going to have most likely have issues.
So systemic inflammation issues can range from,
you know, headaches, chronic,
I mean, going with a list of symptoms a by a long.
So I'm going to give you an example.
I had a mother and father come with their young girl
who had ADD, ADHD.
This kid was literally bouncing off the wall
and I, that's kidding you, would I use that phrase?
Already gluten free, already dairy free.
We did a genetic test, we did a 23 of me and this child.
She had both, her HNMT, I think she had a defect
of every one of these genes but one.
And she also had multiple comp defects,
which we're going to talk about,
done the role of which affects the neurotransmitter dopamine.
So she had excess dopamine because of the
drop defects, excess histidine.
So we put this child at a low histidine diet
and we cut out proteins as well because proteins
are going to be the precursor for dopamine.
So we cut out the precursors for dopamine
because they had excess dopamine
and we cut out histidines in the diet
so that we would not continue to feed this cycle.
The parents called me several days later
saying we have a completely different child.
And she said, no, you don't understand.
We've never seen her before, like this.
She's a different human being.
I had a Tourette syndrome child.
Tourette syndrome is where they get stopped
by the bloodied up expletives
because they have excess dopamine in the left frontal lobe,
which is where your broken area is for speech.
And with that excess dopamine,
it's a very excitatory neurotransmitter.
It just builds up and they just have to express something.
That child had a very similar genetic variant picture.
Did the exact same thing with them.
Cut way back on proteins, which are feeding the dopamine picture
and cut off histidines.
The mother contacted us two days later
and said that the Tourette was down 80%.
So you could make a tremendous difference
in a person knowing what their genetic picture is.
Does that make sense?
So don't take this lightly.
You can see dramatic changes in people.
So why would you, this is HNMT,
which gets rid of histamine in the tissues.
There's the pathway.
Histodine goes down several pathways.
This is a low histamine diet sheet that we use.
That is assuming people are out of paleo diet already.
And we send this to people.
Things that are the gray area are higher in histamine.
Those are the things you want to cut out
to decrease or eliminate if it's really bad.
So anything that's aged has more histamine.
Eggs are in the gray area.
Eggs have histamine in them.
The more aged the eggs are, the more histamine they're going to have.
If you have your own check-ins in your eating fresh eggs,
they have a lot less histamine.
Even leftover food has more histamine than it had yesterday.
So fermented foods that are so good for your gut,
why are they so good for your gut?
Because they contain so many probiotics.
Also have a lot of histamine.
So I said, we can't use fermented foods
with the person that's got a lot of HNMT and ABP1 defects.
Okay, so we have to use other things.
Does that make sense?
We also have to be careful with glutamine
because glutamine is very good to heal your small intestine.
A lot of products have glutamine in it.
A lot of gut-healy products have glutamine in it.
Our product that we created has glutamine in it.
But you want to stay under a grave of glutamine a day.
Especially if you have cancer
because glutamine can feed your cancer.
And some people that have a lot of bad defects
that we'll talk about later
and other gluten defects, there's multiple glutamate genes.
You want to stay away from glutamate altogether.
Okay, still following me?
So I know it gets kind of complicated.
It does, but it's complicated.
There's just no other way to put it.
You have to look at the big picture.
I just wish it was like, okay, just stop eating this
and all your problems are gonna go away.
It just doesn't work that way.
So you have to look at this puzzle of our body
and look at it as a puzzle
and there's a ton of different pieces.
And if you could get the majority of the pieces,
you could see what the picture is.
The more pictures, the more pieces you could put in there,
you could get a better idea of what the picture looks like.
Wherever it go to be, 20 years old again.
We're always gonna have degeneration.
There's no getting around that.
We live in a fallen world,
but the more pieces that you could put together,
you could get back to the level of health
that you're comfortable with.